well joining me now for more reaction to
this is Larry Elder he's a former 2024
Republican presidential candidate uh
Larry I want to get to that about
schools but I get to get your reaction
you were a presidential candidate now
that Maine is joining Colorado and put
denying Donald Trump to be on the ballot
uh hoping for the Supreme Court to weigh
in here what's your reaction to
that well the Supreme Court will weigh
in and in my opinion this is this is a
could be a stretch Jason but in my
opinion the Supreme Court is going to
rule 9 zip that this so-called
Insurrection Clause ought not prevent uh
Donald Trump from being on the ballot
it's ridiculous absolutely absurd he's
never been charged with Insurrection let
alone convicted of it I thought they'd
at least wait for him to be charged but
they didn't even do that so this will be
smacked down pretty severely by the
Supreme Court at some
point yeah I I I tend to think you're
right there Larry all right let's go
back to the other topic which is the
schools because look I know you care
about the schools but there has been an
IND
that is manifested itself into these
kids and and it is one of division it's
not uniting the country it's not about
what Dr Martin Luther King talked about
it it's totally the opposite of
that you know speaking of of King in
1966 Jason he was on British television
and he said the changes in America have
been so rapid and so positive in the
last two years since the passage of the
Civil Rights Act in about 40 years time
we could elect a black president almost
on Queue Barack Obama got elected I was
in Boston in the arena when he gave his
coming out speech and he said there's no
blue America there's no red America
there's no Black America there's no
White America there's just one America
United States of America electrified
everybody unified speech 2008 he's on 60
Minutes being interviewed and he's asked
if you don't win will it be because of
race and Obama said no it will be
because I failed to articulate a vision
that the American people can Embrace he
walked into the Oval Office the third
week of of uh January 2009 Jason polls
show blacks and whites thought race
relations would improve what did he do
for eight years One race card after
another after another from the Cambridge
Police acted stupidly when they did not
two if I had a son he'd looked like uh
if I had a son he looked like Trayvon
when the man who shot and killed Trayvon
was found not guilty and the juror said
race had nothing to do with it he
embraced black lives matter a divisive
movement founded by Co by self-described
trained Marxist Marx was a guy that
fathered the narrative that the world
can be divided between the oppressed and
the pressors he gave a speech and he
said that racism is in America's DNA he
had Al sharpen over to the White House
excuse me almost 80 times Eric Holder
his AG once said that America when it
comes to race is a nation of cowards and
he talked about pricious racism and one
example he gave of pricious racism was
voter ID race card after race card after
race card near the end of Obama's term
two officers in New York were killed
execution Style by a black man angry at
this false anti-black police police
narrative uh five people were killed
officers killed in in Dallas by another
black man Angry over the same thing
three killed in Baton Rouge by another
black man Angry over the same thing so
Obama made things worse when he had a
golden opportunity to take the country
into a different
direction you know Larry I I I got to go
back to this breaking news coming out of
out of Maine because I look at the
hysteria that surrounds the idea of
Donald Trump and his ascending to the
presidency you know at one point Joe
Biden actually said you know we got make
sure he doesn't even get on the ballot
he said something to that effect and now
you have Maine joining Colorado coming
up with a conclusion not about saving
democracy not about enhancing democracy
and allowing the people to vote for who
they want to vote for but now the main
secretary of state is not allowing
Donald Trump on the ballot I mean where
has this country come
to well and don't forget Joe Biden is
the one who referred to mag Republicans
as semi fascist Hillary for the entire
time of Trump's term referred to him as
illegitimate said 2016 was stolen nobody
accused her of undermining the
foundation of our Republic you had Jimmy
Carter who claimed that the Russians put
Donald Trump there when Jay Johnson
Obama's DHS secretary testified under
oath that the Russians failed to change
a single vote tally so they've been
saying it time and time and time again
nobody accused him of inciting a riot of
of being insurrectionist but Donald
Trump says I want you to peacefully and
patriotically make your voices heard and
he's an insurrectionist it's outrageous
and it's going to set the country on
fire if the Supreme Court does not
overturn these election these these
decisions yeah and part of the absurdity
of what was happening in Colorado is the
Supreme Court there rules that not even
write in ballots I mean did they forget
the fundamental thing that the
government works for the people it's not
the other way around you're not even
going to allow somebody to be written in
to be considered a vote for somebody and
this is how they I mean I'm tired of all
the preach that's coming from all the
Democrats across the country just saying
hey you know what we Donald Trump will
destroy democracy Donald Trump never
tried a trick like this it's a dirty
trick and it is wrong and is going to
divide this country and is going to
ignite people if they can't vote for who
they want to vote for and what they're
doing in Maine I'm telling you other
states are going to try to do these kind
of shenanigans again and the people of
this country are not going to stand for
it and the Seven members of the Colorado
Court were all appointed by democrats
yet three of them disagreed with the
decision by the majority so when it gets
to the US Supreme Court where six of the
nine have been appointed by Republicans
I believe it's going to be overturned as
I said nine
nothing well I hope so I hope it gets to
the court sooner rather than later
because they have got to be able to
weigh in on this and put this to bed
sooner rather than later it's a
distracting to the primaries that are
just over two weeks away and it and it's
denying people their fundamental rights
what about the other candidates that are
trying trying to get some time in the
airwaves and be able to actually make
their case to the American people and
what about the rights of somebody who
has never been convicted of anything
never even charged of anything you're
going to deny his ability to even be on
the ballot based on what there is
nothing that can justify this and for
all those liberal pundits and all those
people say and including President Joe
Biden Joe Biden's the one that walked up
to the microphone and say well it's so
evident or he used some par phrase of
that that of course he did no he wasn't
and if he was why wasn't he charged with
it he was never charged with it as you
said and he was never convicted of it in
fact all those January 6 riers look if
you did something wrong then go after
them but they were never charged with
Insurrection either it's a very serious
crime to be involved and engaged in that
but that is not what had happened it's
not what
happened it's called Trump derangement
syndrome Jason maybe someday there'll be
a
vaccine
well they can't get that vaccine
fast all right uh Larry Elder thank you
for weighing in on that tonight hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else